hey guys as you may know i did a tedx
talk in the summer about my experience
with the lion diet the all meat diet
that put my autoimmune disorder that
caused crippling arthritis and gave me
two joint replacements into remission
i followed tedx's guidelines very
carefully as i'm aware my experience
with diet is anecdotal i finished the
talk asking the medical system to look
into the diet further
we spent the last four months going back
and forth with tedx because they won't
post the talk i was the only talk from
that tedx conference that they refused
to post they said my talk went against
their community guidelines but couldn't
name exactly what it went against and it
didn't like i said i was really careful
since then harvard has put out a study
on the carnivore diet that i've linked
below showing other people who have also
had success putting their diseases into
remission
this is something that should be taken
seriously and looked into tedx is
supposed to be a place for new ideas and
novel thinking and anecdotal reports
they have tons of vegan talks claiming
veganism cures diseases but my story
didn't make it through because it
violated community guidelines they can't
name so i decided to put it up here
enjoy
hi my name is michaela peterson and i'm
here to talk about how i put my
idiopathic autoimmune disorder and mood
disorder and chronic fatigue into
remission with an extreme elimination
diet
of only eating meat
but i will start at the beginning
when i was two
i started walking with my feet out like
a duck
and by the time i was in grade two i was
walking down stairs one foot at a time
complaining that my shoes were too small
and i was diagnosed with
juvenile rheumatoid arthritis active in
37 joints
i was put on methotrexate and naproxen
to get my symptoms under control
and had cortisone injected into 17 of my
joints
in grade two i was sitting
on a chair in class
because i couldn't sit on the carpet
because i couldn't sit on my knees or
cross my legs i was using this really
ugly fat pencil because i couldn't hold
a pencil because i couldn't close my
hand
when i was in grade four i was put on
enbrel a biologic immune suppressant and
i started injecting myself with enbrel
and methotrexate twice a week and i was
put into a medically re induced
remission
and i went on all the sports teams i
could go on i went from being nearly
wheelchair bound
to playing sports
at the same time my mental health
declined dramatically and i started
experiencing ocd symptoms
and suicidal thoughts and i was put on
ss horizon diagnosed with major
depressive disorder
potentially bipolar type 2 with
hypomania
when i was in grade 8 i started
experiencing the sensations of
mosquitoes biting my whole body
and chronic fatigue and by chronic
fatigue i mean i couldn't wake up and i
was falling asleep in class
by the time i was in grade 11 my
arthritis had gotten bad enough that
it had destroyed all the cartilage in my
right hip
and i stopped being able to sleep
because of the pain and was put on
oxycontin and when i was 17 i had my hip
replaced
while
i was healing from my hip replacement
my body destroyed all the cartilage in
my left ankle
and i ended up
walking on basically broken bones
so i had my ankle replaced so that was
17.
i went off to university and my mental
health deteriorated further
i was they tried to stabilize me with
wellbutrin
and i ended up having a grand mal
seizure at the university library they
tried to stabili stabilize me with an
snri and i was so angry i felt like i
could claw my skin off
but a year and a half into university
this gets better i swear
about about a year and a half
about a year and a half into university
i was so fatigued that i missed my final
exams
and i dropped out and went home
when i got home i started experiencing a
rash on my back and on my bum and then
on my face and when it got to my face i
thought okay arthritis is one thing
idiopathic hypersonia or chronic fatigue
is one thing
chronic depression is one thing but like
a rash on my face i cannot handle that
and i started researching
december 2014
the rash stopped healing
and i went to dermatologist after
dermatologist and they said you know
stop doing this you're anxious i was
like okay that's not super helpful
so i figured if i don't figure out
what's wrong with me i'm going to die
because my body was destroying its
tissues
at that point i was on tylenol 3 to take
at night because the shoulder pain was
so bad from the arthritis that wasn't
kept in check that i couldn't sleep
i was taking 40 milligrams of adderall
just to wake up in the morning because
of the idiopathic hypersomnia i was
taking dapzone which is used an
antibiotic used to treat leprosy so that
my skin would heal i was taking 40
milligrams of ecetalopram for the
depression
i was taking an inhaler because if i got
a cold it would turn into bronchitis
that would turn into pneumonia night out
in the hospital because of the immune
suppressants
i was taking
a prescription strength antihistamine
because i was so allergic to trees and
grass that i was verging on anaphylaxis
in the spring
anyway there were more
so
i started researching and i came across
this rash eventually called dermatitis
herpetiformis which is the skin
manifestation of celiac disease which is
an autoimmune disorder that can be
triggered by gluten and i thought
holy [ __ ] is it
is it celiac disease the whole time
so i cut out gluten i went off of my
immune suppressants which weren't really
working anyway given the fact i'd lost a
hip and an ankle
and i started monitoring my symptoms
really closely to look for flare-ups
in september 2015 i reduced my diet
further because cutting out gluten
wasn't enough and i thought if i'm going
to be doing this for the rest of my life
researching trying to figure out what's
wrong with me i might as well rule out
diet so i went down to meat and greens
and certain root vegetables that i
didn't really like like carrots sweet
potatoes parsnips
i cut out all the foods that i thought
could be potentially causing
inflammation and that month my skin
healed
for the first time in a number of years
i lost three pant sizes of bloating i
didn't know i had
two months into that
my fatigue went away for the first time
since grade 8 and i stopped taking
adderall
three months into that diet
my depression went away for the first
time in my entire life
and i went from living in
hell
to
being in heaven
a hell that i didn't know i'd been
living in
and i thought okay well i'm not taking
any drugs ever again
and i stopped taking my ssri
over a two week period without realizing
because nobody told me
that ssri withdrawal exists
and for the next two years
i had
the most horrific experiences of my
entire life and that is saying something
i i reintroduced
soy a couple of weeks after i went off
of ssris and i had a full-blown
autoimmune response
and it started with my digestion was
upset my entire body got itchy the next
day my depression was back worse than
i'd ever experienced and i got into the
shower and thought how could i be so
arrogant as to think i could control
this disease with diet and i cried
four days later i had mouth ulcers my
arthritis was back my rash was back
and
i got my brother to drive me home from
my parents
because i didn't think i could drive
and i got out of the car and i went to
my apartment i turned around
and my brother's head
looked like that
for about two seconds he looked at me
and he went off and then it was my
brother again and i thought oh my god
i just talked stopped taking all my
medication and now i'm insane
so for the next year i went in and out
of what i now know was ssri withdrawal
mixed with an autoimmune disorder and
food sensitivities and i had 24 day long
reactions each time i tried to
reintroduce a food
about a year after that i figured maybe
i'll just stop reintroducing foods and
not experience this and at that time i
got pregnant which i didn't even know i
would be able to do given all the
medications i'd been on
i went down to meat and greens to try
and get my
symptoms under control
and a year after that i was
breastfeeding getting out of bed my
wrist buckled i thought okay i have to i
have to do something because i'm worried
i'm going to drop my baby the arthritis
was back i was itchy everywhere and i
was like how is this possible if i'd
experienced remission why isn't that
diet working anymore and i cut
everything out
except for beef
and two weeks after doing that
thinking i'm nuts and hopefully i don't
get vitamin deficiencies
the itch went away and my joints started
to feel better
four weeks after that so six weeks after
an all beef diet the depression lifted
and i stopped crying in the morning
and five months after that the anxiety
lifted and i was back in what i felt was
heaven compared to how i'd been living
so that's all beef all lamb salt and
water
now i've been talking about this diet to
spread awareness and to hope in hopes
that the medical community can take
something like this seriously
my mom went on the diet and her
osteoarthritis
went away my dad went on the diet and he
lost 70 pounds his gerds went away he
had psoriasis that went away i've talked
to thousands of people with autoimmune
disorders who've done similar things and
seen similar results
so
that is me now that is my kid
i'm a ceo i'm a podcaster
i try to share my experience to get
people to see what this kind of diet
does for me i call it the lion diet
because
it's not cool to be this restricted and
it's not cool to have an autoimmune
disorder and people who are sick feel
isolated and miserable
so i'm trying to make it cool but what
would be really cool would be if the
medical
community could take this seriously and
do some case studies
that's it